oh
wow jeez what the hell man still in
control no overwhelming feelings of Rage
no a normal amount of rage you do revert
back to Gen 4 when you sleep with the
air horn really necessary for comedy
absolutely
this is a multi-year journey you're
about to embark on
who's your best friend Nikki expandex
spandex is your best friend being a Hulk
asks for balance
[Music]
so much more to learn
yes so I'm clearly nailing it at all
these things
if you want to go back to life as a
lawyer I I respect that
he doesn't mean that
more and more eccentric superhumans are
coming out of the woodwork
we are going to launch a division for
them and I want the She-Hulk to be the
invasive
Jennifer Waters
Namaste I have a serious conflict of
interest this man tried to kill my
cousin Bruce yeah that's quite all right
oh
people only care because I'm
representing Emil bonski I think they
care because they're like hey that
girl's green
Jen do your thing good I really like
this outfit
I'm not proud of this
I just want this we answered to a higher
power our universe is on the edge of a
precipice
I am a lawyer who do things by the book
The Book of Ashanti no the book of
American laws
whether you like it or not you're now a
superhero let's do this
you know that friend you have in high
school
it's way cooler than you were attractive
got all the attention from everyone
[Music]
I think I'm jealous is that what I'm
feeling
[Music]
foreign